My name is Tamzin.
Partner development manager in the UK and Northern Europe
I started working on mobile content since 2001.
I want to say that this industry is booming.
I am very excited
I am really happy.
See the Android ecosystem we built
Can let all partners
Discover huge potential business opportunities from it
I think everyone has heard a lot about monetization and improvement today.
Obviously, profitability is not just about pricing strategies.
Today, everyone listened to Ellie and Michael.
Sharing some practical tips about quality as the cornerstone of success
Tips for design
Also about using beta testing
And the secrets of platform tools such as staged release
Some of you may have participated in Matteo's interactive skills lectures.
That lecture was really exciting.
Mainly introduce how to understand your users
Thereby increasing engagement, retention, and understanding life cycle value
Let's take a look
Let’s first take a look at the current emerging business opportunities.
I know we talked about this earlier today.
Mark introduced you to the welcome speech.
Android platform can not ignore the development momentum
And what I want to convey here is
There are huge profit opportunities here.
And there are more and more payment methods that people can use.
We mentioned this before.
However, it is important to emphasize that the carrier issuing gift cards and local payment methods such as PayPal.
Can develop new target audiences for everyone
In fact, I have seen such an example with my own eyes.
When we launched a new payment method in New Zealand
Really attracted a new batch of users
And increased sales
This means we are indeed in New Zealand
Found a new sales target audience for you
They will buy content
So far, we have witnessed great success
Several key figures can reflect this
We opened up the domestic market in Germany
After we launched a new local payment method
The number of buyers has achieved 70% year-on-year growth
Still want to share with you
Google Play’s monetization
Our main international sales
Achieved 38% year-on-year growth
In this growing global market
How do you price your high-quality apps?
Please note that I especially emphasize "high quality" because you have listened to various practical suggestions today.
And I believe that you will put these suggestions into action.
The global market is ready for your product
You have built the application and improved the application design.
And are using various platform features
Then, pricing for globalization is very important
One of my respectable colleagues, Yoshi
He is now debugging the microphone somewhere
After I finish speaking, he will discuss with you about the topic of entering the global market.
He will give you a detailed introduction
Other elements related to this aspect
However, I want to talk about it first.
Several key points about setting and managing prices
You might say, Tamzin, these are common sense.
Although some of them are indeed common sense
But the developers who actually put these into practice are few
Less incredible
So today I want to quickly explain these key points.
If everyone thinks it is too boring, I can stop and return to my seat.
These key points include the pattern matching the market
Consider purchasing power parity
That is, the price that consumers can afford and the local price preference.
As Purnima mentioned before
0.99 pricing model is not successful in Japan. This involves audience segmentation.
You need to check your pricing strategy regularly
The first is to match the model to the market.
We know that there are multiple user charging models on Google Play.
Including free, free value added, paid, subscribed, etc.
Therefore, it is important to ensure the pricing model
With the target country
Cultural and economic factors
This is very important
If in the country you're targeting
Prepaid is an absolute mainstream spending habit
Then the popularity of credit cards may be very low.
At this point, you may want to consider using a payment model that is more focused on the transaction.
Such as in-app billing or payment, etc.
And take into account the user on the phone
The frequency of recharging may not be very high
Of course, your pricing model should
Support the value proposition of your content
For example, if you offer a subscription service
Then make sure the content or features are updated regularly
Or let the user have reason every day
Come back to get more value
Has anyone heard that we have lowered the minimum price in India?
Please raise your hand
well
Does anyone really lower the price and enter the Indian market?
awesome
I really want to send you a fruit basket.
This is the case, we have recently lowered
Lower limit for developers in the Google Play India Edition store
From 50 rupees to 10 rupees
Now let me explain the background of doing this.
I can see that a can of Coke is about 10 rupees in India.
But the price in the US is $1.
That's right, that's it.
But actually we all know
If you press yesterday’s exchange rate, $1 is equivalent to 66 rupees.
That is
The price of a can of cola in India is 10 rupees in the United States and the price is 66 rupees.
From this example we can easily see
Coca-Cola is actually based on the purchasing power of the market.
That is, purchasing power parity to determine the price
Well, this example tells us
Although there is a market exchange rate
But there is always a price that is flexible according to the consumer’s price.
Can bring you more conversions
Just four weeks after we lowered the minimum price
We saw some results
220 developers targeting India
Adjusted the price of 560 products
So, this gentleman, you are one of the 220 developers.
In the end, these developers’ revenues increased by 800%.
The effect is very good
In addition, it is worth mentioning that
Is your company in India or in the UK?
Oh, in the UK
That's right, 75% of the 220 developers are not in India.
But it has adjusted the price for the Indian market, including you
It can be seen that this is a highly international market. We are very happy to see this situation.
I especially want to share with you the practice of Nova.
Nova's product is a browser launcher
Its original price is $4.99
Equivalent to around 325 rupees
That is the price of 32 cans of cola
They use this promotion
Adjusted the price, I remember it is 15 rupees
On this chart we can see the effect of the adjustment
Order volume increased by 136% and revenue increased by 27%
The effect is proven again, and the developer is happy too.
Yes, this offer is still going on, if you are interested
And hope to enter India, it is recommended to seize this opportunity
We know many of our top partners
All of them carry out price tests on their own
Recently, an excellent learning app
Made some ABCD tests in the US and Russia
They found
After testing four different price points for the US
The best price is 23% lower than the original price
But the conversion rate has increased by 95%.
ARPU increased by 52%
The test results for Russia are similar, the price needs to be lowered by 12%.
Everyone can see the relevant statistics on the screen.
It is important to note that there is no need to apply their results.
Because your content is unique
You also have your own target market
But if you want to find a way
Test different prices for the target market
I can use this method to find the best price.
To help you increase your conversion rate and get more
The following questions to be discussed are mentioned earlier.
I am from Australia, not New Zealand.
Something makes me very upset
I am going to the Play Store to find an app.
Finally found the favorite application
not bad
At this point the system shows that I need to pay 1.16 or 3.74 US dollars.
I feel, oh
I feel that developers don't care about this user.
We introduced before
In Japan, people like integers, such as 700 yen.
Do not like 701 yen
So in the developer console
We allow the price of in-app SKUs to be customized by country
Paid price or subscription price
The most intimate thing is that after you set the price
We will convert the price to local currency
This way, when the user sees the optimized price
And when it comes to their valuable products
If they like the content, they are more likely to buy
Has anyone attended the interactive skills lectures of Matteo?
very good!
It seems that everyone is familiar with this.
But I have to talk about this topic again.
Because the degree of interaction is very important
As we all know, no two users are the same.
So you better know who your customers are.
Their behavioral characteristics are what they will pay for what they buy.
With this information in place, you can develop different strategies.
Helping users during their shopping
Matteo talks a lot about Google Analytics.
In fact, all analysis tools are important
In fact, if you have a way
Segment customers
Find out who will spend money on shopping and who will not spend money on shopping
Who is happy to interact and who are not willing to participate in the interaction
Then offer them different products or services
It will be a great success. There are so many examples.
For example, Wish uses this method.
Some of you have not heard of Matteo’s speech. Therefore, I will give a general introduction here.
Wish took some steps to increase conversion rate
Mainly to provide different product combinations
Provide cheaper products for less interactive users
Offer more expensive products to users with higher levels of interaction
Is anyone here selling products to Russia?
There are some
Then you may be familiar with this picture.
However, a best practice to mention at the end of any pricing method is
Check pricing regularly, this is fundamental
For example, if a developer
No adjustments were made within one year after the price was set on February 1, 2014
Then he will find his total income in Russia.
Almost half cut because the exchange rate has changed
Therefore, we recommend that you regularly check to see if pricing is reasonable.
For example, is your pricing appropriate compared to your competitors?
After the exchange rate changes, is your pricing appropriate?
These are all the best practices I want to introduce.
I am speaking a bit slower. Now I have to go to the next topic.
This theme is
No two users are the same
They have different price sensitivities
Have different needs
When you enter the global market
How to deal with this situation?
So next I will talk about AdMob
Then I will introduce you a little more.
Our latest updates on subscriptions
Remote control, give a little force
Is anyone using AdMob here?
If not used, I will not be disappointed.
well! Great!
I will introduce AdMob first, which is convenient for the audience who have never used it.
AdMob is our industry-leading advertising and mediation platform
In the past two years, it has helped more than 650,000 developers
Earned more than $1 billion in revenue
Everyone can see here
All aspects of growth are amazing
These numbers reflect some of AdMob's situation.
But actually it reflects the situation of the entire ecosystem.
As can be seen from these figures
Advertising is a very important way to profit
And growing every year
In fact, Gartner had predicted
This is Gartner's chart by 2017, and the number of app downloads will be close to 270 billion.
They think that most apps download
Will use free, paid or free value-added models
Development of freemium model
No doubt means the development of mobile advertising
We have discussed
Due to discrepancies between disposable income and culture
Consumers in different markets have different behaviors
But we think that developers should not be allowed
Only monetize with in-app ads
Or can only monetize with ads
However, we have not provided this option to developers.
Until we launched AdMob
AdMob is designed to help you find
Appropriate profit model
It provides a lot of opportunities to process information
Watch your apps, users, and advertisers
Then provide them with the right experience
In a nutshell, this means you can make settings in your app.
In this way, we judge users who like to consume
Will see in-app purchase ads in your products
And those of us who don’t like spending
Only see AdMob ads or third-party ads of your choice
We try to help you monetize all users in this way.
Not only rely on users who like to spend
Not limited to users who don’t like spending
This is another tool in the audience building tool AdMob.
Use this tool to gain insight
And create more granular audience segments.
Thereby offering them different products/services
Let's say if you have some users who are happy to spend money on your products.
Then you may not want to show ads to them at all.
The AdMob platform will let you do this.
So in-app purchases and advertising are two great ways to monetize.
But there is another way to make money.
Does anyone here like to continue to earn income?
very good!
So, let me introduce you to the subscription.
Ask another question, who has a Netflix account?
awesome
Who is using the mobile phone package?
Everyone can see
Subscribing to this mode has proven that users are used to it and like this model very much.
From the user's point of view, this mode makes people very comfortable
Because there is no unplanned cost
After user registration
You can continue to enjoy the content for free
In addition, users can build trust in the brand.
For developers
Continuous income will make you more confident about cash flow
And help estimate the investment on Android
Do you know?
Subscription is the fastest growing business model on Play
It can be seen from the statistics here.
2013 to 2014
Subscription model has increased by 2.5 times
We think this is because of two factors
The first factor is
People are getting used to paying for apps and content
The second factor is the top developer
For example, everyone here, constantly improving
The quality of the apps you launch in the Play Store
So thank you very much
I have timed out
So I will introduce a few cases, the first one is Busuu
This is a very good partner for us.
Last year, they were on their Android apps.
Put a lot of money
Their focus has always been on improving the user's ability to get started.
The purpose is to attract users to sign up for subscription services.
They completely modified their designs
Enable users to actually see
Value that can be obtained after registration
Many of them are free
Ending is a call to action
In addition, I have to say that the New York Times is awesome.
They used to use the paywall mechanism
Now transitioning to the Google Play billing platform
The time they need to register the user
Reduced from two minutes to only three seconds
The reason why registration speed is so fast is because
All logged in users
There is already a payment method in the Play Store.
Thanks to the simplification of this
Subscription conversion rate increased by 125%
so
You can use a lot of features to build a successful subscription business
The grace period mechanism we provide is very useful to allow users who have run out of time to recharge their time.
Because the user may be using a prepaid top payment method
Carrier billing function may be a problem for a while
Or the user did not pay their credit card bill
In general, the grace period gives users a chance
Let them resolve payment issues without unsubscribing
This is not only beneficial to the user, but also beneficial to you.
Because this will reduce the customer churn rate
To reward customers who provide practical feedback
Quality customer credit is a very effective mechanism
And upgrading and downgrading is another
A means to help users easily complete a purchase or ARPU journey
The next slide
I am most eager to share with you today.
But what excites me even more is
starting from tomorrow
We will launch a quarterly and semi-annual subscription period.
This allows you to achieve many different goals in the past
The first is to use psychological principles to price
You can adjust the pricing method of the product
Subscribe for six months compared to one quarter
The former is more attractive to users
Again, we hope that this way
Give you more flexibility in terms of monetization
Thank you very much!
I am overtime, I am very sorry.
But I still have to summarize
First, Google Play is a growing market.
I think we have said it many times today.
Pricing is a booster for profit
But quality is one of the key factors we have to consider.
Follow some best practices and you can succeed
Please think about the subscription model you can use now.
thank you all
[applause]
[play music]